late last night big ruling from a judge
by Administration Now set to appeal that
ruling by a federal judge out of Texas
which blocks the president's student
loan forgiveness plan remember this is
400 billion dollars I want to bring in
Dave Rubin hosted the Reuben report Dave
good morning to you as I'm looking at
the computer uh Reuters is saying right
now that student loan debt relief has
been blocked that's according to one of
these eight websites
um uh that is up and running here Dave
this is stunning you had 26 million
borrowers apply you had already 16
million approved and a judge said you
can't do this because you went around
Congress
yeah I mean I don't know where it says
in the Constitution that the president
of the United States who's the chief
executive I mean he's supposed to sign
things into law he's not supposed to
make law I don't know where in the
Constitution it says that he can just
wipe out people's debt uh you know I
have a mortgage I'm guessing you
probably have a mortgage bill can can
Biden just wipe out our mortgages with
the stroke of a pen that would be very
nice so I tend to think that this
federal judge from Texas is correct and
you know the real issue here is that the
Democrats really all they have left is
to keep quote unquote giving to people
of course it's not really giving because
it's not Joe Biden's money it's our tax
dollars to pay off other people's debts
no one's forced to go into debt no one
is forced to go to a four-year college
and you know especially because now
colleges you know you go to a place like
Syracuse University I'm just picking one
off the top of my head it's something
like 60 Grand a year so you walk out of
there you're 240 240
000 in debt and have you learned
anything and are you equipped to go out
into the workforce I get why the young
people are upset that they're not going
to get the relief at least at the moment
but it doesn't make it right to just
wipe out other people's debt there's
plenty of good people who have paid off
their debt myself included yeah where
was this idea when I was coming out of
college
exactly
man believe me you don't know
um the White House is saying this is all
extreme Republican special interest in
charge here pushing for this here's what
the judge said in this country we're not
ruled by an all-powerful executive with
a pen and a phone instead we're ruled by
a constitution that provides for three
distinct and independent branches of
government the court is not blind to the
current political division in our
country but it's fundamentals of the
survival of a republic the separation of
powers has outlined our Constitution be
preserved if this goes the U.S Supreme
Court I don't know if it will or not in
all likelihood I mean you look at the
makeup of the court right now that they
may lose on this we'll see colleges and
universities are sitting on 700 billion
dollars in endowments 700 billion if all
those schools got together yeah somehow
Harvard Harvard ain't giving to that
money back Dave no no student America
would have to pay tuition again if they
forked over that cash okay that to the
side you used to live in California
right you moved to Florida two years ago
has it been
uh it's just under a year actually I
believe 11 months and six days okay time
flies but it doesn't fly that fast
um here is Ron DeSantis Victory night
the other night here's how it went watch
we saw freedom in our very way of life
and so many other jurisdictions in this
country Wither on the vine Florida held
the line we chose facts over fear we
chose education over indoctrination we
chose Law and Order over rioting and
disorder I mean you know the results he
won by 19 points and that's that just
give us a sense because you're a newbie
to Florida about how people there are
reacting to this outcome
oh man it's off the charts I was
actually broadcasting that night about
100 feet away from the stage the energy
in that room was was unbelievable but
really what's happening here in Florida
with this 20-point win is that people
have just said enough of the woke stuff
enough of you you know encroaching on
our children and taking more of our tax
dollars and everything else how about
competent governance and that is what we
have done here at every single level
including let's not forget bill just
what about six weeks ago we had one of
the worst hurricanes in the history of
the United States and the rebuild there
including the Sanibel Causeway and the
Pine Island Bridge was almost immediate
I've met a contractor that uh just two
nights ago at the DeSantis event who was
doing some work on it he said that if
the federal government had gotten
involved it would have taken them two
years it basically took them two weeks
there is such incredible energy in this
state right now they're building houses
everywhere they're redoing roads uh you
know people obviously don't have state
income tax there is a Feeling that our
education system will work better
because we're pushing the woke stuff out
DeSantis is basically doing exactly what
everyone asks politicians to do give us
the room to live our lives as we see fit
and then pick those those brief moments
where the government has to do something
he's doing it brilliantly well and I
think that was the best speech he has
ever given he's he's stepping into the
moment and that's why he's getting so
many attacks by the way at the moment
because people are realizing this this
is the real deal we'll see what comes
next Dave nice to see you not looking
back at California clearly or the taxes
that you're left no sir thank you Dave
nice to see you today if you're looking
for more honest and thoughtful
conversations about politics instead of
non-stop yelling check out our politics
playlist and if you want to watch full
interviews on a variety of topics watch
our full episode playlist all right over
here and to get notified of all future
videos be sure to subscribe and click
the notification Bell